Now on to the differences
between Swift and Objective C.
Let's start with how they handle nil.
As you know, Swift treats nil
values with a great deal of care.
Wrapping anything that could have
a nil value in an optional type.
Objective C is much less
concerned with nil values.
The language doesn't need
the concept of an optional because
any object can have a nil value.
No problem.
Surprisingly, in Objective C, you can
invoke a message on a nil pointer with
relatively little consequence.
Watch.
Here's some code that represents
a bike messenger picking up a package.
Here, I'm initializing a messenger and
then he picks up a package.
Now let's press run and
since we've got a log statement here,
we can look down here in the console and
see package contents, top secret stuff.
Now watch what happens if I
set the value of the bike
messenger spike to nil.
First of all the compiler doesn't care.
If this were Swift the code
would even compile.
And then when I run the code,
it handles it like it was nothing.
Down here in the console,
we see package contents null but
there's no crash, there's no null
pointer exception like we get in Java.
Now in this toy example,
the fact that nothing happens when we
invoke a method on Spike isn't such
a big deal, but in general you don't
want your program doing nothing when
it's supposed to be doing something.
You may find yourself
frequently checking for
nil values even though they
won't crash your program per se.
Objective C's relaxed
attitude toward nil values
also has some implications for
debugging which we'll talk about more in
the lesson on interoperability
between Swift and Objective C.